oh you know we could have a tarantula
can we get one no hi I'm Hannah and I'm
the world's okay it's mom now for the
past few days we've been dog sitting my
coworker Kelsey's dog and he's adorable
he's so cute and the kids are just in
love with him which has made me realize
that we don't have a family pet we've
lived in rentals for so long that don't
allow pets and now we're in a house and
we can finally have one so I've decided
to take the plunge and we're gonna do it
now I've seen you guys comment on
previous videos that you'd like me to
let the kids pick our family pet I
figure why not let's try it
fingers crossed that it's not a snake I
can't deal with any reptiles but we'll
see what the kids day wish me luck
first we need some ground rules for this
rule number one nothing illegal
hedgehogs are cute but they're not legal
in California and I'm not ready to go to
jail on behalf of my children wanting a
particular pet second nothing dangerous
I don't know how to care for certain
animals giant boa constrictors pet
scorpions not willing to risk my life
for that third rule is we need to stay
within a budget I feel like such a
broken record I'm always like budget
budget keep within the budget but
seriously we don't need like a $1,200
exotic cat and last the pet has to be
realistic so getting a pet that our
house can't accommodate or that I can't
properly care for cuz let's be real my
kids are six in three they can say it's
their pet but who's gonna be doing all
the work so I'm sorry if you clicked
this thinking Oh Hannah's gonna get a
komodo dragon or a Python I love you
guys but not that much if you could pick
any pet in the world what would you pick
Oh be a check a shark just where we
gonna keep it we're gonna keep it in our
pool oh my gosh I could see that coming
from a mile away and from there I
realized that the best way to present
this to the kids is to show them all the
viable options so we did a little
research
john casick guinea pig guinea pig don't
bear it but those are illegal I think
and here's the thing you're both very
allergic to cats they are so cute and so
cute cats are so cute yes I know but
you're allergic you guys were like
breaking out in hives and stuff I love I
love cats so we spent a long time
whittling the list of animals down and
we finally got to a place where both
boys decided that they wanted to start
by looking at dogs we are on our way to
just go take a look at one of the animal
shelters near our house just to see what
we're working with
are you guys excited
someone's excited so we walk into the
pound and the first thing we see is
little white dog on a volunteers lap
sitting right up front my kids just
beeline towards this dog I know my kids
and I know how kids minds work and it's
the first thing they see they're like
yes I want that so we decided to do our
due diligence be it to lose the entire
shelter kept going back to this white
dog checking on her she looks so sad
there was just something about her face
it's a way that she got to the shelter
was she had escaped from probably the
backyard of her owners house and the
shelter found her owners and they came
and she saw them and she was so excited
thinking she's going home and her owners
decided to leave her there protip don't
walk into a dog pound unless you are
fully prepared to take dog home with you
I'll just put that out there because we
have a dog
[Music]
so when I told my family we were coming
home with a dog they were literally at
our house waiting for us to pull in when
we got home this is Rosie Rosie girl or
as I like to call her Rose day cuz
you're still fancy you are can I hold
her yeah so what the rest of this video
I will be perfectly content to be like
this anchored anymore so after a couple
days we were a little more settled in
you know the honeymoon phase of just
bringing a dog home wore off and we had
some work that we had to do something we
noticed when we were playing with her in
the shelter was I can't think of a nicer
way to put this but she kind of smelled
like a dead body when they gave her the
exam at the pound before they released
her to us they told us she needed a
teeth cleaning we are headed to her
first vet checkup are you ready yeah
probably when I took her in for the
checkup at the vet I was expecting to
schedule her to be spayed and have her
teeth cleaned at a later date but upon
examining her the vet realized that she
was in a lot worse shape than we thought
okay so the vet found that her teeth
have been severely neglected so the vet
said that her tooth decay is absolutely
atrocious and she might need to get some
extracted because her teeth clearly were
never cleaned and she said that she
probably is in a lot of pain but then
the vet also found flea bites all over
her and a ton of scratch marks all over
her old and new from scratching at the
same spot over and over because she'd
obviously had untreated fleas for so
long that just makes me feel so horrible
I'm glad that we're getting it taken
care of I hope she feels so much better
after this in my opinion this is worth
every penny and this is exactly what we
have to do for her she is a member of
our family and this is what we have to
do so I'm feeling I'm sad I feel really
sorry for her
okay we are back in the car from the vet
and sorry I like can't even think right
now
she lost 22 teeth she had to get 22
teeth extracted because they were in
such bad shape
her entire upper jaw has no teeth left
and I know that it's gonna make her feel
better and you know her quality of life
is going to improve so much
but it just it was that wasn't necessary
you know that could have been prevented
so easily and I feel so bad for her cuz
they said she's gonna be in a lot of
pain and it's gonna be an adjustment for
her I got and I just I wish we would
have found her sooner so she's laying
down here she's bleeding out of her nose
and out of her mouth and she's currently
on a lot of pain meds and they gave me a
bunch of pain meds so she would stay
comfortable for the next five days but I
just I was not expecting that much
I'm just so sad
well we're home I'm just gonna let Rosie
relax in her bed I had to put the cone
on her because I was worried that she
was going to start licking her stitches
from being spayed so I feel badly that
that's around there and she's probably
so uncomfortable but we're gonna have to
work really hard with the boys to be
gentle with her right now
because I don't want her to associate
them with pain or fear she had to get
some surgery we're gonna have to let it
heal and she's a knocked-up some soft
food for a couple weeks
Rosie is still very much on medication
right now she's very loopy and confused
she doesn't quite know where she is
definitely not afraid of the kids
hurting her which is nice
she just brows at us she growled at them
yesterday because she was not feeling
great but I think she didn't want to be
touched so the next two weeks rosie was
in full-blown recovery mode for me it
was like having a newborn again twice a
day antibiotics pain medicine every day
she hated that cone and I wasn't gonna
make her wear that at night it's just it
didn't seem fair so I stayed up and I
checked her all night long to make sure
she wasn't getting up to lick her
stitches it was a lot I'm talking about
you being a good dog so after two weeks
of recovery Rosie was all better what
that surgery did for her is
indescribable she was coming out of her
shell and feeling so much more
comfortable so we decided to take her to
get groomed for the first time Rosie are
you excited to get groomed you excited
to get groomed so we can see your eyes
yes
while Rosie is a family pet and she was
kind of both kids decision she was
predominantly Jackson's choice Jackson
definitely had a stronger opinion on
whether or not he wanted her so I wanted
to give Wyatt a chance to
have something for himself too if you
could pick any pets you want to go look
around and see what there is check it
out okay
it was going back and forth to every
animal looking at all of them again he
would say that he wanted whatever animal
was in front of his face at the time I
want a gecko no I want a guinea pig no I
want a snake so after going through the
store multiple times I think why it kind
of realized what he was looking for
because he's a kid who's very
independent so he ended up picking a pet
that's just like him it's official so I
like Wyatt named the fish and to be
honest I have no idea where the name
came from but I think maybe it has
something to do with the fact that he
ate waffles that morning so I want to
extend a warm welcome to the family -
our second pet syrup pie person why are
you so happy so when we first decided to
let our kids choose a pet I was really
nervous and I definitely expected the
worst and kind of brace myself for a
disaster but here we are now and life
with our two pets is amazing my kids are
capable of making good practical
responsible choices these pets have also
taught all of us a lot about
responsibility and not just the
day-to-day duties of having a pet but
the long-term commitment that you make
when you decide to get a pet it taught
us all what can happen if you don't take
that responsibility and you don't care
for your dog and give them exactly what
they need if you're not ready for the
responsibility of a pet and I mean the
full scope of it don't do it because it
breaks my heart that Rosie had to go
through what she went through for all
those years and it never needed to
happen that's all I got for today I'm
Hanna and if you have a pet shout them
out in the comments let's all be pet
parent friends or you can always text me
this is a real number and I don't always
answer all of them because I get a lot
but I do read every single one now if
you'll excuse us rosie has some business
to do and you guys don't need to see
this tell
[Applause]
[Music]
she says like a person
Rosi you sit like a human you look like
a little kid